good morning good afternoon good evening
everyone welcome back to GameSpot's best
of 2017 countdown we are about to
announce our number eight game of this
fantastic year yesterday we announced
what remains of 8th Finch was number
nine and Nier automata was our number 10
game I'm Mike McCarty here with Peter
Brown I'm still here on this couch in
this damn sweater and Jake Decker hello
you haven't moved yet no you smell very
bad and Alessandro Ferrari
we're about to roll a montage of our
number 8 games so without further ado
let's show you what it is
[Music]
[Music]
Johnny Damon to talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so there you have it hell blade Center
was sacrificed from Ninja Theory over in
the UK got our number eight spot a bit
of a surprise I guess that game was
going for some lofty goals and they know
that Alessandra you reviewed this game
earlier in the year what are some some
big things that stuck with you after the
many months that have passed well first
off I just like to say Jake did a great
job with that trailer yeah it was great
yeah the presentation mostly is what
stuck out to me I came in as a big
admirer of ninja theories past work
particularly for enslaved and DMC Emily
so it was okay but you know yeah I feel
like seeing their the games they've
released like there's their approach to
presentation and story as has refined
greatly and you know we're seeing with
help with hell-blade we seen we're
seeing them basically at the top of
their game yes this is possibly the best
work they've ever done in terms of
presentation which really stuck out to
me and yeah you know you see that you
know worked into the gameplay but also
the the storytelling too because the
game uses some really clever tricks to
present its story though its main
character is suffering from severe
mental illness yeah so one of her
symptoms of psychosis so like it can
manifest as you can hear voices in your
head you can see hallucinations which
plays into the puzzle solving so it's
kind of a tricky subject to tackle
especially in a medium so young Jake do
you think they pulled it off yeah I
think they did an incredible job and we
kind of touched on this we did an
episode of reboot on this and one thing
you pointed out was how you know films
have been around for quite a while now
still relatively young but like video
games are so new yet they managed to
take a subject that hasn't really been
tapped and do that well especially in
video games and they they they really
nailed it
yeah sure and then like obviously like
some of the pillars of game there's the
combat which you know you look back at
like their DMC
you looked at enslaved you looked a
heavenly sword you know they can do that
third-person action combat but in this
one it's a bit different because you're
actually kind of you're dealing with
like light and darkness you have to
bring the enemies out of shadow to
actually be able to hurt them in certain
cases and it can get challenging but
then there's also the puzzles and again
part of the manifestation of her
psychosis that she sees things other
people won't Pete when you were playing
through hell-blade do you think the
puzzles in the combat contributed to the
overall sense of like empathy for cinema
or helped you understand her character
better the combat side of things maybe
not so much that was like really
exciting and interesting in its own
right but definitely the the sort of her
magical beliefs that would lead her to
see things through these gates in the
world and that was necessary for you as
the player to to figure out how to
progress and how to you know unlock
doors and access new areas and that
certainly helped me sympathize with
someone who struggles to really grasp
reality in the way that we all do and it
made for an interesting gameplay
mechanic that perhaps was used a little
bit leaned on a little bit too much but
I also think that it was one of the more
interesting mechanics of the year just
across the board yeah they also used the
binaural audio so if you wear headphones
you get a lot more out of this game
because you're actually hearing things
from separate ears and you're actually
kind of feels like it's floating around
you and then also you're talking about
the presentation with senua so the
motion capture and voice actress just
one like best performance at the game
Awards she actually started off on the
team I believe I think the story is that
they just were using her as like a test
that person yeah and then they really
liked her and so they included her but
that facial capture I remember it was
back at like a GDC in 2014 maybe when
they first showed it she was up on stage
with the capture equipment it's just
fantastic the emotions it can capture
and you really need to do that in this
game Alessandra you were talking about
the presentation like did that binaural
audio and the actual visual presentation
add to this story of cinema oh
absolutely uh there are a few moments
were you know the binaural audio like a
it comes in the form of like these sort
of dueling inner voices that you know
sort of a either complement to you or
say you know you're not doing great
basically in the game they refer to them
as the Furies but uh but yeah I mean
that dad just it created a lot of weight
just for the character like you I felt
for like considerably like you know and
just then again going back to milena
Jergens like you know she did a
fantastic job on this game like that
she's a first-time actor too which is
you know incredible so yeah yeah I felt
just I felt for this character immensely
throughout throughout the game yeah it's
tough because it is a really grim story
I mean like even outside of they kind of
like there's parallels between what's
going on in this their pits like a pict
tribe from way back in the day and
obviously again you don't really they
didn't have like mental illness
diagnosis back then they didn't know
what to label them as so it was even
harder for her to convey to the people
close to her and you started finding out
we won't spoil anything but you know you
start finding out that it did affect her
relationship with other people as it
often does and I in our lives and
everything so it was pretty grim and sad
to see and it's tough to replay the game
but Jake you've been replaying it like
to capture and make that montage did you
find it like the game I was had even as
much impact a second time around
yes I think it has just as much impact I
wouldn't say I was having fun replaying
it cuz it like you walked by you're like
I really like this game but I don't
think I would ever want to play it again
and that's kind of how I feel but it's
not like I I wasn't like dreading
playing it I was still really absorbed
into what I was playing it was just like
this is it it's it can be a tough game
to get through like it's only what six
hours but it felt longer than that yeah
I mean you see the what what is this
boss fire here to remember the name suit
suit and then yeah there's the vol raven
and you can do them in any order before
you progress but did you like Pete the
kind of Celtic picked setting that they
oh absolutely yeah and it was
interesting too because right around the
time Alessandro recommended a I can
never pronounce the directors last name
it's from Valhalla rising from Nicholas
yeah so before I played this I had
watched that movie and it is this sort
of you know we always sort of like focus
on always reminded us of Vikings or
Norse stuff but it really is its own
thing definitely in history but
definitely in terms of just like you
know presenting a world and it and it
just the the sort of sinister side of
everything that that bled through like
the environments the you know the script
just it was also like I mean hell-blade
is the perfect name it's a hellish
existence for
they're kind of a terrifying aesthetic
and I forever how much that stuff is
authentic in this game or in that movie
I don't know but those combined gave me
a real appreciation for for what that
can do in modern entertainment yeah with
the footage were watching right now we
just saw whoever's playing almost died
which brings me to my next point about
perma death there's kind of a many many
controversy surrounding this game and a
first release people were upset I lost
John directly tell me a little bit about
what happened basically the the mechanic
is called the dark rot and after you die
basically uh you know the infection will
spread and if you die enough times then
the infection will take over her body
and it will permanently kill her wiping
all your progress in game yeah yeah wipe
your saver counselor playing yeah and at
first people thought it was them just
saying that to increase the anxiety that
she was feeling but it worked in that
regard yes I felt like more conscious
about not screwing up yeah and how many
times did you actually have to die for
it to take effect was it different like
based on your difficulty or as they said
later that there is this mechanic is in
place but it might not have been working
when I first released yeah there's been
some conflicting things about it but I
played on the hardest setting and I died
maybe like four times yeah yeah I mean
for the moment but again going back to I
said earlier for me like just presenting
that made me extremely anxious about you
know going through the game and you know
whether it was true or not and like I
feel like it doesn't matter because it
worked
yeah yes I mean like if you want to
connect the player to send well like
each time you see you're about to go
into a fight rather than be excited like
[ __ ] this could white my save if I die
enough time this is very emotionally
invested in every way like yeah that's
crazy and like for them to do that with
such a kind of McCobb grim story is uh
pretty impressive and then I do also
want to talk about the business angle
quick so this was a thirty dollar game
people are calling it like a double a
game right you like you have so many
games from away yes you have so many
games coming out with microtransactions
and they're saying well games are super
expensive to make so we have to include
these to actually make back what we were
spending on the game and what we were
investing in it but then you have Ninja
Theory who figured out like a budget and
then they figured out a price point that
you know they were hoping would work for
them and then we just saw recently they
cross
at least 500,000 copies which is great
for them the smaller studio in the UK
they donated a lot of that profit
haunted organizations that helped people
struggling with mental illness oh yeah
got like what an awesome story all
assumption board
yeah design-wise like as a work of art
as like a business standpoint it's just
like a great precedent hopefully for the
closure of videogames right yeah in
general yeah sure and just looking at
the game you can tell like you know this
does not look like an indie game at all
no no this is positive again going this
is ninja theory at the top of their game
when it comes to visuals and they did
some amazing things with the technology
like a sort of the live motion capture -
you know in game assets yeah ology they
showed at GDC
which was you know I'm sure like you
know will help them out and whatever
project they have next so you know yeah
I did a lot of amazing things in this
game and in that vein I mean certainly a
lot of their know-how came from working
with bigger publishers on bigger titles
so it's not like we can expect most
indie devs to achieve what they've done
here but it is a good sign for Studios
that do struggle as they grow to you
know maybe they don't always need to
chase bigger and better things maybe
they can really just you know double
down on the things they do well and make
something interesting yeah so as we're
looking back on like one of the better
years in memory of releases and video
games all asunder what was like the main
thing that stuck with you and like when
you think about how blade kind of
mention this earlier but what is it that
you think about now is we're going
toward the end of the year and talking
about all these best of 2017 lists
definitely the visuals and presentation
again like you know just seeing well
also of the fact that this game cover is
mental illness in a fairly respectable
way I think there are a lot of gay other
games that maybe use that subject as
like sort of a plot device or like you
know it's a twist or whatever but you
know seeing a main character and staying
with her for the entire game and seeing
her experiences through her eyes and you
know where reality and her perspective
you know which is you know altered by
your illness and seeing that both of
those like come together as one in the
same is to me it was very profound and
really effective and I haven't seen a
game like this that you know the
affected me so deeply yeah I've been
thinking about it since like even after
the review was published so yeah
absolutely stayed with me same here I
don't know that I could put it any
better than that
that's hell blades sending with
sacrifice from a ninja theory over the
UK congratulations to all the success
they've found with it on a from a
business standpoint a great precedent
hopefully for other developers to take
notice which I'm sure they already have
and just from a design wise I hope other
people can follow in this vein of
empathizing characters we might not
usually understand as well but if you're
watching this on youtube or GameSpot
after it's been published go check out
the rest of our game of the year
coverage number 10 was near automata we
announced that on December 11th and then
on December 12th we announce what
remains of Edith Finch
rounded out the nine spot again we will
be announcing our number seven game
tomorrow at 10:00 a.m. on the 14th
that's correct kind of losing track of
time but thank you so much for joining
and obviously keep it at i/o for that if
you're watching this live we are gonna
jump into hell-blade right now actually
as usual we've been live streaming these
games so I'm gonna have alessandro pick
up a controller and we will get right
into it do we so this is right after you
said with valle raven fight and suit yes
you have to fight these two and either
whatever order you want and then you
continue across the bridge deeper into
Valhalla if I'm not mistaken is that is
it not Valhalla sorry like hold on help
I'm the artist yes you guys have to
watch that holo rising like yeah still
really get that recommendation yes that
was one of the yeah most surprising
films I had never known about cuz he did
the pusher trilogy and then Valhalla
Rising and then and then only God
forgives
what about neon demon do you really know
I'm just kidding I will go to bat for
only God for you alright maybe I'll ask
you to convince me to be watching and
after cuz last time I watched it I just
did you go into only God forgives
expecting like driving Bangkok yeah yeah
kind of like I but I also watched enough
of it and I knew I've watched enough
like commentary with divining roughen to
know that he was kind of at least from
my perspective he's kind of being
self-indulgent at that point if drive
wasn't but I love drive but anyway so
yeah this is right after you kill those
two bosses
I think Valle Raven is maybe not
objectively but in my perspective the
harder one yeah oh yeah like just
replaying and I think I eat soup first
tried bball raava the first tribe but it
came so close its ball Robin you have to
do the
perspective puzzles to get to him oh
yeah those archways which can become
tedious if you take a wrong turn because
then if you come back through the
archway it's not like resets it
literally just yeah anytime you walk
through it it'll reset the person what's
happening the environment her
perspective but again if you miss it and
then come back it'll twist it the wrong
way they're not the wrong way but like
from your perspective it'll seem the
wrong way yeah this is a very like
plastic moment right here yeah the
harrowing and foreboding like clouds
that hang over most scenes yeah I
thought I was right in front of the door
but I guess that did not have saved
there but that's okay we get a little
calm before the storm
this is on ps4 Pro correct it is it
looks great fairly good yeah one of the
upgraded games that I really noticed
yeah I haven't played this since I
released like I said early since we did
that reboot I played it like
one-and-a-half times but yeah I was
tough to get through in a not good way
yeah and a good way that's a good
challenge for personally challenge that
way yeah yeah like they they said they
got the inspiration from the pic tribe
like it's pretty not forgotten but it
was a pretty uh yeah sorry art TV in the
studio is kind of dark that's all good
um the picture I was like not much was
known about that I believe like Scotland
was the last place they were seen a long
time going ninja theories trying to find
some place to set this game
you can see a little bit of that rock
crawling up her right arm yeah yeah it's
pretty gross looking the first thing
that happens to her when they first tell
you about it yeah it crawls up her face
is pretty yeah
gross yeah when you're going to suit and
then afterward I mean even later on
there a lot of puzzles based around fire
I'm just avoiding it what you want to do
it's it's very weird to play this game
without sound though yeah it is such a
wonder
oh we got some sound there you go I
actually played the full game with like
headphones like yeah yeah you should if
you can highly recommended even more so
than other games this dude what else
does he voice acting I'll look it up but
he's a great voice actor he's uh he's in
a few other like big-name things he's
awesome he's like your guy I guess you
could say one thing I also love is the
we kind of talked about it before in
that discussion but like the voices in
your head and like it's such a video
game trope right to have that voice like
think back to fable like do you have any
food potions your health is low or
whatever and like this actually makes
sense in the world like they're like
look out behind you watch out but at the
same time they are punishing - yep
Dillion that do you talking or Dillion
you're like that's a sin it was a former
lover Jillian Jillian it's my joke is
that coach Coach coach shines no I
actually forget the exact reference but
it's substitute teacher no oh
either way let's
I think of German and he also voiced he
was in battlefront too apparently
well the way the camera moves around her
it doesn't really cut
yeah not having cuts like new it makes
everything really seamless and like you
know you're always yeah you're always
ready to like get back into it just in
case
[Music]
she appears but without us they came
through storm taxis they raided these
shores
he's so
since soundtrack for this game is great
to decide was the closing credits that
sounded like it took like I'm emo metal
turn oh yeah I do remember that I
believe that Kombi Christ can contribute
to the game which they also did work on
DMC oh okay oh man I'd love that game so
much yeah I hope they do a follow-up to
it but I mean I'd rather get this stupid
I never played enslaved yeah definitely
the PC version is definitely superior
version goes like the black came out on
consoles are some issues with the ring
ring come on cult classic right yeah
yeah mm it's 10 or 9 L 11 minutes oh
look guys we were in the ballpark to
like 98
speaking of like a pict in the setting
the pig tribe in the setting is just the
character designs unreal like the
between everybody's like got the outfits
they've designed everything yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe this wasn't the best response he's
a pretty good example of just how it's
true just how far this game can go I'm
feeling like it it also but I like yeah
we said it right I think there's combat
coming up yes yeah there's a pretty big
combat not that not that we need it but
maybe good palate cleanser oh the
whisper like the whispers with the by no
our audio is so yeah developing the
possibly one of the best effects in the
game yeah
passage dramatic shifts yes I mean it
like can it in another way else yeah
like it conveys her the bipolar nature
of all this but she'll be super
optimistic the next minute and then her
hypose will fade there's that one scene
near the end shouldn't spoil anything
but where she's we can't win the flowers
you know like and there's that tree that
like is like almost other than like
walking back from that area is like one
of the few moments of reprieve that's
like no it's really well done Stephen
this right here it's gorgeous but then
you look at how sinister that like the
architecture is yeah and I love how
that's almost like over you almost the
entire time look you can see that
somewhere it really gives place to the
world aren't there something like a
developer's call those weenies I'm not
joking really yeah they're renals yeah
like we not there there used to actually
give you a sense of direction all the
time like the Last of Us does it really
well with the bridge and it's buried in
the distance Uncharted games do it well
Naughty Dog in general does it really
well all right what's it called
Sudha's recent free-to-play game before
never oh let her die let me die yeah
yeah that's one thing I talked to some
Witcher devs about a year ago and that's
one thing they said when creating the
world was like everywhere you look they
wanted like something to so you know
where you are yeah without like looking
at a UI map yeah I mean breath of the
wild is probably yeah that is ingre
nation combined with the climbing and
the gliding
and then yeah it's like for those who
haven't played you get the pretty what
they call it just like glowing token on
her belt when that's flashing you can do
like John focus okay yeah when you flash
them you activate your focus you can
either like stun these people slow down
time I guess it's not stunning it's
slowing down time so you just hack them
to bits but if they're like in the
shadow still it brings them into the
light so you can fight them nice that
guy looks so stupid and also that's your
that's dillion's head on your belt yeah
that's the thing too
[Laughter]
as one of the first time you fight a
huge dude yeah
kind of a side note but when I first saw
the early trailers for the new God of
War the reboot it's like over the
shoulder melee combat was kind of
worrying me and concerning me like I
don't the obviously God of War used to
be more like Devil May Cry third person
character action but then we're playing
this game if I go maybe they could pull
it off because they under you seem to
figure it out like fixed perspective but
I bet you gotta four will have a lot
more it's trying to juggle yeah at least
in terms of the combat yeah a crevices
development has always been one of the
strong suits of those games yeah okay
good that's the focus kind of stumbled
into that nice though
I love her animations like she's clearly
a well-trained warrior but she's also
super like maybe not sloppy but just
brutish yeah yeah you like the way she
like she does that extra step after a
heavy like it almost looks like she's
like his neck you can feel the weight of
the sort of door strings
she almost looks exhausted to when she
follows through with some of the swings
and near the end this game throws so
many enemies at you - yeah there's that
one part where you're waiting through
that like knee-deep I don't know if it's
water but liquid of some sort and you
just when you think you're done but your
route says something and he's like you
thought you were free of this and then
you have to fight another twelve half of
them are in shadow you have to bring
them out and there's a couple big guys
that come in you're juggling everything
the counter is super satisfying - yeah
yeah there we go
right on cue the shield do this yeah I
will
like a stager
man just thinking of thinking back to
like this game kind of came out of
nowhere like everyone knew about it but
I mean not everyone knew about it but
like we knew about it for a while right
but like yeah let's say the I think the
name sounded a bit generic to me at
first yeah looking back as like oh it's
perfect but at first is like oh what is
this hell-blade : what how you say her
name
Sinhala yeah I mean at the time I was
wondering Oh considering like where we
are now their understanding of what this
game is and how great it turned out
looking back to sort of the lukewarm
attention that it received announced
that he was at GDC Europe like 2014
we're like well that's interesting the
theory is doing something smaller okay
yeah wonder what that's gonna be like
hopefully it's like DMC it's like we had
no idea what we really wanted from them
or well you know what we should have
hoped for abs and combo attacks to
psychosis personal sacrifice yeah the I
remember when they first announced a my
initial response was like Oh Mantid it's
not sound like it's gonna turn out well
read you're trying to do what with a
video game I mean how do they edit they
pivot from this yeah yes seriously I'm
curious what sort of impact this had on
them as as creators as well it just sort
of steeping in
in this atmosphere for years so this is
a good example of like environmental
using the environment like solve those
puzzles I love where they take it though
eventually where it's like you're
looking at the world in different angles
in order to build paths to get through
yeah it's one thing like to have that in
the game but the fact that like when
psychosis manifested often you see
patterns in the world that other people
don't the fact that she's actually kind
of accepting it and trying to use it as
best she can is uh
pretty awesome awesome not the best word
but I mean the way that they conveyed it
was great it's clever yeah
just a breathtaking looking game as well
this is sort of thing when I see a game
that looks like this I like don't worry
about when the next generation of
consoles is coming out yeah I'm sad I'm
totally satisfied with what I'm seeing
here
the lighting is unreal yeah and the
superimposing of different like I mean
like there's some like live-action stuff
superimposed over like I'm not wrong
right yeah yeah yeah just like the way
that doesn't seem to there's no like
harsh contrast between the two styles
like it just it just [ __ ] works
I feel like it's tough to do something
like that really the use of live-action
I send the video right yeah Oh weird
yeah it definitely works better in this
game sure it was a bit jarring seeing
that enslaved they blend it in a way
like we're just like it contrasts like
clearly like intentionally with the
individuals and just so creates a
surreal quality to
so level of the X yes
how many times you uh have you played
through this cell so I'm doing two or
three I died twice yeah hard I went on
hard mode for the first time
no catch and so I like those I don't
they're not tombstones but those like
little monuments kind of give me a
backstory whenever you do it when you
find out what happened at Dillion and
sandy was again it makes it even more
heartbreaking
I don't know there's like the rating no
I mean we don't have to I mean we've
been talking about spoilers on these
live streams but I guess we've already
gone this far without spoiling this it
is a short enough day baby but yeah it's
just like you find out like what it adds
guilt to her story that makes it even
harder to digest
do you feel like it sort of ties back to
the the beginning of the story when we
joined her as someone who's more or less
being outcast yeah for sure
yeah cause like that's her her dad like
kept her isolated for how long because
of her symptoms and they no one knew
they just assumed she was totally insane
then her mother actually had similar
yeah you know issues as well and you
know she was also like treated as an
outcast yeah they viewed it as a curse
it was a curse yeah that's what they
were saying so he's like they
essentially made it sound like her dad
put her in like a pit and then uh
Dillian was one of the few people who
treated her like a human being
her mom right it's a bit more
complicated but
sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
the way they parallel the actual like
ragnarok happening in the world with her
internal struggles is pretty amazing
yeah
it's - laughter playing this game I had
to like do research on like all the
aspects of like the Norse mythology and
yeah the pict cultures
it's Affairs I've seen by our in our eye
but what if each one of us is always
dreaming even when awake and we only see
what are in a high grades for us
is this what Alice World shaded by
Santa's nightmares
maybe that's what people fear seeing the
world through her eyes
because we believe that Sun is reality
toasters
yours might lead to
these monologues are also well written
to see
did you really think the heatwave
the first time you see her saying these
things right here
[Applause]
yes yeah you have to do that the trials
to get the sword from the tree later
right now that's going on yeah I've got
another five minutes in this and then
call it a stream Freya what happens now
I know you're unarmed for a while right
yeah you said that rock crawling up well
a little bit more
snow is like the thing with it - is that
it crawled up just as you progress -
like it wasn't even just dying because
like I don't think I died a whole lot
but by the end it was like of my arm and
it seemed like yeah for everyone it was
like up there often if not further I
think for like the separate cutscenes
stuff they had to like account for how
far was up your arm right they had to
show it based on your playthrough for
each cutscene by the end it's like all
the way up yeah
I'm just still blown away that this is
actually from the first time mattress to
like yeah form it's like just fantastic
we're saying Molina Jurgen Jurgen yes
yeah yeah that was the first time I ever
saw her was on the stage the GBC they
were demonstrating but it looked like
he's too literally two cameras came up
and pointed right at her with the
sensors on her face and but it was like
it was it renders in real times they had
the screen up to the right and so they
were capturing it as she did it they
didn't have to like run it through
anything else it just like showed them
what it would look like I was like I
wonder if they would have access to that
kind of stuff like you said if they
didn't have that triple-a background I
don't know what kind of that technology
is getting more affordable and in
smaller it's been around for a long time
but but yeah it's the sort of thing
where I think you're gonna see it used
more often just be as it becomes more
prevalent and economical well if you
watch they're like behind the scenes
they did it like in an office like it
looked like a really like janky setup
but yeah clearly I mean it didn't matter
right was he like LA noire facial
capture which was how long ago yeah
seven years at least but much better
than la more
okay
I feel like a glass of water would help
her feel a lot better yeah she was not
in a good place
understatement daddy actually she rarely
left the house my father's in Bethel
made sure of that
yeah looks so good occasionally did you
venture out
- firewood it hurts parents are the only
blades
like this one
and some of those trials are terrifying
to you I forget what are some ones you
think one is just your complete ear and
complete darkness and you're just
listening oh that's right and then yeah
there's the one where the fires chasing
you through the hallways and then
labyrinths kind of like the darkness
when you yeah cuz do you really use that
binder all audio really comes in because
you hear like things moving in front of
you around you and then you like stumble
up and almost touch one you be like and
half done yeah cuz I played a lot of
this to capture or just the play in the
office but then I think I finished it at
home like a night and it was pretty
riveting
yes she
also the level design is just great how
it snakes back in on itself with the
puzzle then like it's kind of like a I
don't know I don't to say Dark Souls but
it's really good in the level design how
it doubles back and you create shortcuts
back to the places you need to go
for the record I didn't say Dark Souls I
said I don't
yeah this game had a lot of people on
staff like I'm pushing hard for it not
even hard like I don't think anybody
wasn't disagreement there was a special
game no this is one of the easier ones
to yeah and it actually started like
outside of the top ten that we based on
our phone based on our votes and it was
like like six of us were like we need to
yeah maybe more no Jess McDonald and uh
au office think this was one of her
favorites if not her favorite of the
year this is my personal number two yeah
yeah I think that number for me yeah
we got two more and Adam in the UK did a
really good video on the business side
of things how it's oh it's a pretty good
precedent and kind of a breakthrough in
a way maybe hopefully for development
costs and development just don't wake up
call yeah you don't need to be working
yourself to death I mean I know they
worked hard on it but you hear all these
horror stories about crunch and this
great game cost X millions to make and
they sold this many copies and most of
the money went into their next project
crunch under the pressure of milestones
set by investors who owned a publisher
that you're like beholden to at every
turn but you say you want to call here
showed enough cool all right yeah
I mean like we said if you haven't
played hell BladeCenter was sacrifice
you should absolutely go do that thank
you everybody who stuck around for the
stream again Nier automata was our
number 10 game what remains of Edith
Finch was number nine by giant sparrow
and ninja Theory's hell-blade Senna was
sacrificed a fantastic game conveys
empathy for a character that other media
might not be probably wouldn't be able
to great presentation great design the
way ties it all together is fantastic
great precedent on ninja theories part
and we had a ton of people on staff that
need this to be high up there and I'm
really glad it got into our top 10 well
deserved in a year of fantastic games as
usual be back tomorrow it's 10:00 a.m.
Pacific to show off our number 7 game
and then Friday we'll finish off the
week with number 6 and then next week
we'll go 5 4 and then Wednesday we'll do
a mega stream for our 3 2 1 games just
so you don't spend a whole night kind of
knowing what our number 1 game is but uh
but anyway thank you so much for
watching again go catch up with our
other game of the year streams and
discussions from yesterday and Monday
and we'll see you tomorrow